welcome back you're watching sky news
tonight the top stories this evening and
a worker at the british embassy in
berlin has been arrested on suspicion of
passing documents to the russian
intelligence service
a new american intelligence assessment
says that the afghan capital kabul could
fall to the taliban within 90 days
and undercover police officers have
described the moments before they opened
fire and killed a terrorist in south
london
[Music]
next uh those fears i just mentioned
that the afghan capital kabul could fall
to the taliban within 90 days well
that's the prediction of a new american
intelligence assessment which comes
after taliban fighters seized nine
provincial capitals no less
in the space of a week well despite that
president joe biden says he doesn't
regret his decision to withdraw u.s
troops and said afghan leaders had to
come together and fight for themselves
so what now awaits the people of
afghanistan well let's get the
assessment of my next guest the former
foreign secretary david miliband he now
works as president of the international
rescue committee of course so very good
to talk to you mr miliband
so after all that blood spilled all
those hundreds of billions of dollars
spent
it seems that afghanistan could be going
back to where it was 20 years ago your
reaction your thoughts
thanks for having me on uh derma this is
a deadly and dangerous situation for
civilians in afghanistan who are the
people served by the international
rescue committee we've got about 1700
staff on the ground all but a handful
are afghans themselves so they're
working for the future of their own
country and just to give a bit of
perspective we know around 5 000 people
have been killed those are civilians
just killed uh in their most recent
fighting
we know that 30 000 people a week are
fleeing the country and we know that
around 350 000
are
homeless as a result of the fighting
notably in the provinces that you have
uh mentioned
the proximate cause of this is obviously
the decision to withdraw u.s troops but
you'll also know
that i've been one of many people
critical for a good number of years at
the time when troops were there was not
used to develop a stable political
settlement for the country and obviously
the great fear at the moment is that the
gains that are being
enjoyed by the people of afghanistan the
gains in education and range of other
areas even in economic development
although remains a very poor country
are on the rack i think it's premature
to say that the gains have all been
already lost
but there's clearly real danger for the
people who we are serving on the ground
today but does it tell us on that issue
of nation building that it's a fine idea
but it doesn't actually work you
mentioned iraq hasn't worked there
hasn't worked in afghanistan and in a
sense the americans
following that analysis and cutting
their losses
well the only people who can build a
nation are the citizens of the nation
but those citizens especially in poor
countries
especially in war-torn countries need
help from outside rather than hindrance
from outside i think that
the clearly the decision the military
decision which by the way is not just
american decision
america had uh about uh two and a half
thousand troops there were eight and a
half thousand nato troops ten thousand
contractors so it's quite a big
commitment that's being withdrawn
that's been decided
but the question now for all of us is
whether or not that military withdrawal
is matched by humanitarian diplomatic
political withdrawal because that really
would increase the danger just to give
you a sense of this british aid to
afghanistan is being reduced from about
90 million dollars a year down to less
than 20 million dollars
a year that's going to put
on the line some of the gains that have
been made in education in healthcare
someone who's leading a humanitarian
organization my plea would be
that those afghans on behalf of those
afghans who have gained in the last 20
years they need support from the outside
world even if it's not of a military
kind because nation building is their
business but they can't do it on their
own given the circumstances that they
face well i mean i'm just interested in
your analysis because there is such a
long history of course some the early
days overlapping some of your period as
foreign secretary was it going wrong
then what should have britain and the
americans and others have been doing
that they didn't do
well i went to afghanistan six times as
foreign secretary between 2007 and to
2010 it was one of the most dangerous
and difficult situations confronting
british foreign policy and in simple
terms i think the mistake
is as follows
the abiding approach and i'm afraid it
ran right through
to the end
was that military endeavour should then
be followed by an attempt to create a
political a stable political system
i argued from the beginning of my time
that those two things had to happen in
parallel and you asked did the troubles
start at the beginning the beginning uh
after the taliban were removed from
power in 2001 was the bonn peace
conference of 2001-2 which excluded
significant sways of the pashtun
population from the southeast of the
country and so the difficulty of
developing
politics that's based on compromise in a
country that's highly decentralized
has been an abiding problem from the
beginning of the effort that's not to
say that there hasn't been significant
gains which as i say have not yet been
erased
but i think it's very important to
learn the right lesson and my lesson is
that whether you're in the military
whether you're in diplomacy whether
you're in the humanitarian sector like
iran
none of them work without an effective
approach to a political settlement and
that can't be done sequentially military
then political they have to be done
together
so let's get to the hearing now i mean
obviously you think the americans
shouldn't be leading this withdrawal of
course britain has to go along with it
but sir the defense secretary has been
saying it is a mistake and trying to get
together some form of coalition through
nato without the americans do you think
britain should try at least to stay
well i hope you'll understand that as
someone who's got an organization with
1700 staff on the ground i'm not going
to comment on the military side of it
because that would just put them in a
danger but i want to speak to four
things that i think are really important
straight away one is the humanitarian
aid agenda this country faces covet
crisis it faces drought in 80 of the
country they need foreign aid secondly
and importantly i think it's vital
that we understand this is a regional
crisis not just a afghan crisis it
involves countries like pakistan in
countries
like iran all of which we have relations
with so that's important this has to be
dealt with at a regional level not just
a national level thirdly it's vital that
those who are in danger in the country
for example because they've served
alongside british or americans as
translators or interpreters they must be
given safe haven i think that anyone
who's in fear of their life should be
given the chance to rebuild their life
elsewhere fourthly and very importantly
there mustn't be a
political and diplomatic withdrawal
it's important that there's a retention
of the diplomatic and political muscle
inside
the country and those seem to me to be
the right priorities for
the present moment which as i say is
deadly and dangerous in all sorts of
ways just paint a picture for us of the
current trajectory if kabul falls if the
afghan government
falls the repercussions uh for
afghanistan of course and all the people
there including some of your own staff
but indeed for the entire world we're
talking many refugees many of whom will
end up in europe and potentially i've
talked about going back 20 years
could we re-establish sea re-established
a safe haven again for terrorist
groupings al-qaeda they're still around
of course and islamic state and others
well you're raising very important and
appropriate
questions you mentioned the refugee
danger that is a real and present danger
to the neighboring states rather than to
countries in europe like the uk or or
the us 30 000 refugees a week that's 100
000 refugees a month flowing into
pakistan which is already hosting 2
million
afghans and into iran which has about
800
000 so the refugee challenge is
predominantly in the region although
some will try to make it to europe as
well in fear of their
lives so there's definitely a refugee
angle it's also important to say
that afghanistan has always been subject
to pressure from its neighbors and from
great powers around it china sees
afghanistan as important pakistan for
obvious reasons sees afghanistan
as
important and for the last 20 years
western countries have worried rightly
about terrorist danger that's obviously
been degraded over the last 20 years but
that remains a reason to believe that
what starts in afghanistan doesn't say
that just want to focus for a moment on
specifically on the plight of women
there i was talking an hour ago to the
former uh women's minister in
afghanistan and many reports now
describing as the taliban retake areas
particularly young professional women
being hounded being forcibly married to
taliban fighters escaping under cover
and indeed being killed in the streets
sometimes it is a terrible situation
well i think you're absolutely right to
raise this there are two things i'd add
to what you said first of all the
greatest gains of the last 20 years have
come to those women and girls who've
been able to go to school who've been
able to get professions who've been
elected to parliament started businesses
working as teachers
so there are real gains on the rank but
afghanistan is a different country
because of those changes and because of
the aspirations and expectations of
those people secondly and vitally we
know that in all humanitarian
emergencies violence against women goes
up significantly and that's certainly
the reality that afghan women are facing
today there are staggering figures about
half of the population expecting
gender-based
violence and that's one reason that
organizations like the international
rescue committee prioritize the needs of
the women and girls who are our clients
it's another reason why i think it's so
important for the outside world to stand
with these uh women because just saying
to them you're on your own doesn't give
them the chance to work on an
on a fair playing field and so i very
much hope people
recognize that it's not just for reasons
of sacrifice that we should stand with
them it's for reasons that afghanistan
needs to be a more stable place and if
it isn't it's a threat to the region and
more widely
we very much appreciate mr milan we are
out of time your thoughts on afghanistan
but just if i may mayor squeeze in a
question about uh totally unrelated
about events in berlin today and tapping
into your deep knowledge of
international relations the discovery of
uh it seems a russian spy in the british
embassy in berlin are you surprised
weren't those days meant to be over
well i i am surprised um not because
the
danger is
not has gone away but because i thought
that we were much better at spotting the
danger but i have to plead that the
first i heard of this
i apologize was in the news headlines
just before i came on and one of the
best lessons of being foreign secretary
is not to talk about things before you
know something a bit closer to a set of
facts than a there in a question so i
hope you'll you'll
allow me to dodge that one oh the old
diplomatic skills haven't gone david
miliband great talking to you as ever
thank you very much indeed